[Musique]
à
tu t'es fixé pages web tu vas nous faire
tuer je peut nous sortir de là je viens
de sortir de là
mais si november ajax
[Musique]
ici
on
on ne fait pas ça ne lâche pas tu lâches
beaucoup trop vite
c'est ce qu'ils pensent
[Musique]
c'est fait
deux ou trois bandes
je crois qu'on l'a énervé tant mieux
tu viennes notre combinaison et comores
il est blessé on s'attaque à ce noyau
des bergers
comment va naître ses rangers lamberth
12 mois bah on est sur une base
militaire tu te souviens comment ça
fonctionne rogers pentecôte
et tu dois être à marana manille oui
messieurs messieurs le ranger bien qu'on
va te montrer des quartiers hauts et
essaie de ne rien volé pendant que tu es
là monsieur garda foot appliquons cost
comme super ballesta cup en cause
pilotent que de tango et rod
pratiquement le monde entier juste un
nom pourrait pas ce nom d'êta my
generation aux bonnettes james tataw
micro de kcra du
et oui mesdames
[Musique]
où
oh
[Musique]
nous sommes nés dans un monde en guerre
entre les monstres qui détruisent et nos
villes et les monstres que nous avions
créé pour les arrêter nous pensions
avoir fait assez de sacrifices
et
mais la guerre qui nous semblait
pourtant terminée ne fait que commencer
[Musique]
et la seule chose qui se dresse face à
l'apocalypse
c'est nous
peu importe que vous menez qui a cru en
vous ou non
ce moment nous appartient nous pouvons
changer le cours des choses
maintenant à nous de jouer c'est ça que
je veux
ils ont évolué elles peuvent anéantir
toute trace de vie
dili non jeu
je pense que je pourrais me faire
à il faut que je montre quelques
chansons
eh ben il est plutôt balèze
[Musique]
bolland fruits tout ce que tu as raison
dis donc
[Musique]
tout
tchèque
ton père a toujours dit qu'il voulait
que tu sois pilotes
il a dit plein de trucs mais je suis pas
un héros comme lui
les cailloux ils vont se reporter
[Musique]
et je serai pas coincée attendre que
quelqu'un vienne nous sauver
cadets préparez vous
[Musique]
ça c'est la fin du monde
comment ils sont entrés dans notre monde
quelqu'un et ça fait entrer quelqu'un
qui appartient à notre monde c'est qui
ça en tout cas c'est pas un des nôtres
tu as une occasion de te rattraper
il nous faut plus de pilote on les a
certains pilotes sont devenus des
légendes mais ne sont pas les héros
ils ont commencé comme nous aujourd'hui
nous allons changer les choses
est ce que c'est bien clair
pilote de jager parce que c'est bien
clair on va bientôt le savoir
c'est sa 2e balle
[Musique]
la journée va être longue on sait quoi
on se bat
[Musique]